so let's begin with this guy prove that
three to the N greater than or equal to
you can write that down it's not too
complicated okay so let's begin the way
we normally do what's the first step in
every proof by mathematical induction
I'm gonna test right what's my first
value of n in this case have a look at
what it has to be tell me my first value
1 this is my my standard one okay now
you can set this out in a variety of
ways the way that is in the handout that
mrs. Liza's provided is a really good
logical one I set out slightly different
they're both fine you said along
whichever you prefer I'm actually going
to start with the right-hand side for a
reason will become clear at about 60
seconds time okay
what is the right-hand side when 8
equals 1 it's going to be 3 but don't
figure it like you actually have to
prove that this is the case I'm gonna
work the simple numbers there and get my
value okay there's my right-hand side
I'm now gonna do my left-hand side again
what's the left-hand side equal to it's
just going to be 3 in the 1 which is 3
now note here you have exactly the same
thing is that okay does that satisfy the
inequality and the answer is it does
because my boundary is included okay so
here and this is why I did the
right-hand side first I know what the
right-hand side is the left hand side is
indeed greater than or equal to the
right hand side do you agree with that
like it it works okay so therefore it's
true for N equals 1 just for reference
the reason why I start with the right
hand side is said that my final line has
the left on the left and the right on
the right if you started with the left
hand side and then you started doing
with the right hand side your inequality
would be the other way around and just
my brain starts fizzling out when I try
to change things around so I want to
avoid that as much as possible that was
the first step the test what's the
second step as you very good so I'm
going to assume that this statement is
true for my particular value K and K is
going to follow all the same rules as in
so I'm going to write that
that K is a positive integer just like n
is so we can just go ahead and write
down the assumption there it is and now
we get to the meat of our proof we are
going to prove true for say it all with
me and equals okay that's why I'm very
good so let's write that this neck in
this next step a bit careful with it
now I just gonna pause here before I
write the rest of the line remember I
said to you before algebra algebra
algebra the most common error I see
especially under exam conditions when
you are in a rush is people will write
this because they like well this there's
the K and then it is going to be K plus
1 it's the next one right what is wrong
yeah I'm missing brackets I haven't
actually substituted K plus 1 where n
belongs
I've substituted K and then I've just
added 1 so that's different
isn't it and you're gonna run into some
trouble later on if you don't have that
correct I'm gonna tidy this guy up a
little bit
that's 2 k plus 2 that's 3 I'm satisfied
with that ok there we go so this is the
statement I am aiming to prove and there
are two primary strategies that we can
use I can aim to get everything on one
side and then prove it's positive or I
could start with this slide here the
assumption okay and then work with that
in this example here I'm gonna have a go
at using everything on the left hand
side so I'm going to get all terms with
k's in them like this over on the left
hand side I want to prove that that is
greater than or equal to 0 that's my
goal okay so what I'm gonna do is have I
got enough space yeah I reckon I'll make
it I kind of want to keep those points
there because they're useful what I'm
going to do now here comes my proof is
I'm just going to think about this left
hand side and I'm going to work with it
okay so the left hand side I'm just
going to write it
character for character 3 to the K + 1 -
3 latest - okay right now just like it
every other mathematical induction proof
you've done so far
I want to shape and form this in such a
way so that I can see this the
assumption in there does that make sense
I want to want to work with this
manipulator until I can see terms that
look like this
okay now you can see there's a three
into the K here on the left hand side
there's a 3 to the K in my line over
here as well but it's kind of hiding
what's sort of in the way of the thrill
of the K on its own yeah there's another
factor of 3 right there so I'm gonna
write it with that taken out so that I
can see it a little more clearly ok now
let me take a brief excursion for a
second and you might want to write this
down on the side another color if you
like to think about this idea remember I
said inequalities are not the same as
equations okay now let me say something
really really blindingly obvious for you
and I want you to write down with me
even though it looks really simple 50 is
equal to 50 right last I checked this is
true okay that means that 50 is also
equal to 49 plus 1 because these things
are the same right but now watch what's
about to happen put your pens down and
look up because this is just it's true
and obvious but weird if 50 is equal to
49 plus 1 then it stands to reason that
50 is greater than 49 just think about
what's happened for a second because
when we've been dealing with equations
right one of the things that's so
important equations is that every single
line stays the same and so far that's
kind of what I've been doing everything
has been staying same everything's were
staying balanced but I've just changed
things right like from this line to this
line 49 plus 1 and 49 are not the same
thing why can I do this transition which
of these is bigger
49 plus one is bigger right
rappy-doo two ladies not for you bra
Becca me okay we'll walk send something
the point that's fine now you're
supposed to call but thank you sorry we
have some visitors don't worry you guys
are used to okay now so where are we
the reason I can do this which you
absolutely cannot do with equations but
you can't with inequalities is that this
is bigger than this right but the
left-hand side hasn't changed so the
left-hand side is now bigger than the
right-hand side
does that make sense I transitioned from
an equation to an inequality now look at
how I can do the same thing over here
okay
do you notice the left-hand side I
haven't done anything to that haven't
manipulated it anyway so it's still
equal to this what would happen if I
switched out this object here for this
object here think really hard over here
what have I done I actually didn't write
it which is a bit sneaky I swapped out
this one for a zero right because I know
that 0 is smaller than 1 so my result is
now smaller on this side right well I'm
switching out 3 to the K for 1 plus 2 K
which one is bigger 3 to the K so I'm
substituting it for something that's
smaller aren't I right or equal so as a
consequence what I now have on the right
hand side should be smaller smaller on
this side right if I do that
substitution does that make sense now
this is what I mean by whoa this is
weird right these two things are not the
same but I have to do that because I
want to turn an equation into an
inequality okay so I'm going to and you
should you should emphasize this as well
right in another color can you see I
have used the assumption here so like
usual I should write that I've done that
by assumption
and I can substitute something for
something different in order to turn an
equation into an inequality this is
weird
if it feels strange in your brain that's
okay it's going to feel strange for a
little while until you get more
comfortable with this idea but it's kind
of the crucial thing that makes these
inequality proofs different to all the
rest of them from here it pretty much
kind of unfolds by itself there's one
more little trick up my sleeve but let's
just expand this this is just algebra
right why do I got here I got three plus
six K minus three minus two K yeah I can
collect some like terms here how many
what constant terms left over the
constant term left is zero what K how
many case do I have any answers four of
them okay but again I've got to think
about my inequalities for a second right
remember K is not just any number look
at the board
what kind of number is K it's a positive
integer here it is so what is the
smallest value that K could take the
smallest value it can take as I've
already tested is one right so I'm going
to say down here I might even put it in
another color just to highlight it and
you might like to do the same I'm gonna
say but K has to be greater than or
equal to one that's what it means for it
to be a positive integer right so
if K is greater than 1 what can we say
about 4k well to get this which has a
cane it to become 4k I'm just going to
do what I would do with an equation and
multiply both of these by 4 that's true
isn't it I do that all the time so if I
multiply the left-hand side by 4 I
should be able to multiply the
right-hand side also by 4 do you agree
does that make sense so therefore see
how the left-hand side which hasn't
changed it hasn't budged one little bit
if it's greater than 4k but 4k I just
said it's greater than or equal to 4
do you see that do you remember when we
saw something like this when we're
working with sine x and tan X and X and
we were trying to prove that limit with
the Radian so we had a set of
inequalities that went one after the
another can you see that the left hand
side is clearly bigger than or equal to
4 are you okay with that what was I
trying to prove what am I trying to
prove I want to prove that it's greater
than or equal to 0 is is 4 greater than
or equal to 0 4 is greater than 0 so
then it's also greater than or equal 0
like that you see how different
inequalities are there different kinds
of objects so if the left hand side is
greater than 4 it's definitely greater
than 0 that's what I wanted that is this
line over here I have just proved it for
K plus 1 okay so there's a little more
to right obviously I actually have to
write this line out down the bottom and
then rearrange it back into this and
then I can say tada I have proven it
true by the principle of mathematical
induction okay